at a point so when we're trying to
predict where we'll be affected we need
to know which direction the faults going
we have a prototype system and that
worked here too so we could we got an
estimate of the fault growing as it was
happening so it's the first time we've
really ever had that work can we talk a
little bit about the motion like to me
it sort of felt like I was on a boat and
I felt a little nauseous I've heard
other people say the same okay so an
earthquake produces energy have many
different wavelengths there's high
frequency energy that jerks you around
and
rolls the high-frequency energy dies off
with distance more quickly than the low
frequency energy think about a boombox
you hear the car going down the street
when it's a long ways away all you hear
is the drumbeat that's the low frequency
energy getting farther than the high
frequency energy so if you feel that
it's a rolling motion you know it's
pretty far away so when I felt the
motion it felt pretty rolling motion and
it lasted for 10 seconds I could
estimate that it had to be at least a
magnitude 6 and it had to be pretty far
away
okay so the basics of the earthquake the
earthquake is near China Lake and
Ridgecrest so the area to the east of
the southernmost part of the San Andreas
Fault the nearest fault is the Little
Lake fault and that it might be
associated with it but we don't know
yeah we have to have a field geologist
to tell us it is a relatively
uninhabited you know it's a sparsely
inhabited area so the number of people
who would have received damage is much
lower I think we need to check what's
happening in Ridgecrest and China Lake
damage reports do not come here we are
seismologists measuring the movement of
the ground damage reports go to the
Governor's Office of Emergency Services
Rob you might ask you to come join us
so Rob graves is seismologist with the
US Geological Survey and a regional
coordinator for Southern California so
let me just tell obviously we're here
because we had an earthquake to
celebrate 4th of July we're going to
have people out our geologists are
heading out of the field right now to
see if they can
fault displacement obviously of any
damage reports will come in
you know this earthquake was large
enough where the shaking could have
caused damage one thing I would like to
note is that here in the only basin area
because as lucy was explaining the ways
the low frequency waves tend to travel
further than the high frequency many
people out in the LA basin would have
felt that rolling shaking we're gonna
sup here in the mountains people didn't
feel it as strongly so we're gonna have
even in the LA area will have disparity
in terms of the reports in the news
cycle usually at this point you're still
asking us what was the magnitude luckily
now we can give it an accurate magnitude
very quickly it's not yet an hour since
the earthquake one comment I would make
if you've noticed we've had a lot of
aftershocks now those in general are not
being felt down here in the LA basin up
in the Owens Valley area I am sure they
are feeling lots of these aftershocks I
haven't had a chance to keep track but
it's we've had dozens I think about
three at this point we will continue to
be having a lot of aftershocks
this area is also characteristically
tends to have very robust sequences the
magnitude five point one happened is
very near this in 1982 and there were a
six or eight magnitude fours associated
with that event as well as dozens of
magnitude threes and it went on for six
months so we should be expecting lots of
aftershocks and some of them will be
bigger than the threes that we've been
having so far I think the chance of
having a magnitude five I don't this is
an off-the-cuff not calculated thing is
probably greater than fifty-fifty
sometime this afternoon we're going to
be
having a larger aftershock within this
sequence question for you considering
its location to the san andreas quality
is there any right no increase in risk
well maybe slightly but we have never
seen a foreshock more than 10 kilometers
6 miles away from its main shock and
this is substantially farther than that
to the San Andreas or to the Garlock
fault which is another large fault
capable of big earthquakes that is
significantly closer to this event and
would probably have a slightly increased
risk on Carlock but I think the San
Andreas is too far away even for this
size earthquake but just keep in mind
that the San Andreas is an active fault
so there is always that risk it doesn't
increase the risk it also doesn't
decrease it exactly can you describe the
activity in that area in the months
leading into this point yeah we we don't
have that data right at hand these no
storms no nothing yeah so if you're
maybe asking me but we have had a couple
of other swarms in other areas of
Southern California in recent days
nothing like that was occurring up in
this area there was a 4.2 of just about
30 minutes before the main shock and
that is a classic for shock but I know
that when I saw that page come through
this morning I went I haven't seen
searles Valley in a while yeah so yeah
and there is also a slight chance that
we could have an event larger than
they're calling the main shock right now
that's about five percent chance for
every earthquake and like any other
quake this probably has about a 1 in 20
chance that this is not the largest
event within the sequence yeah our OB
and les named grades G are a DES
seismologists with the US Geological
Survey we're getting some feedback from
viewers and users of the the alert
system and they say that in Los Angeles
it did not work if it was not broadcast
on shakealert yeah the system worked but
the USGS the traffic elaborating on the
how the system operates yeah so I yeah
and unfortunately I don't have the
details it as do what didn't occur or
what didn't work properly we're looking
into that right now so the system
actually did detect the earthquake it
did work in terms of estimating that
there was shaking that was going to
occur the signal apparently did not get
out so you know the system is still
being tested we're gonna have to figure
out what's going on with obviously we'll
have them take yeah also Connor or point
out and the shaking in the Los Angeles
region was not strong enough to be
damaged don't know I want to hesitate
before making any definitive statements
until I can sort all right the system in
the lab work so that you know physically
at work
the shakealert la system was set up with
agreements that limited which alerts
went out because they get a lot of false
alarms at the lower levels so whether or
not the shaking exceed you know reach
the parameters that should have been
alerted we don't know and we're trying
to find out but remember we're not even
an hour since the earthquake
please we there should if there was
damage in the LA area something's really
weird this was not strong shaking in the
Los Angeles area so I would be extremely
surprised if that were the case but
besides damage notifications do not come
to Cal Tech they are the US Geological
Survey they go to the Governor's Office
of Emergency Services what should always
be preparing for a big one this does not
make it less likely there is about a 1
in 20 chance that this location will be
having an even bigger earthquake within
the next few days that we have not yet
seen the biggest earthquake of the
sequence it's certain that this area is
going to be shaken a lot today and some
of those aftershocks will probably
exceed magnitude 5 which means they
become damaging we do not expect this is
far enough away from the San Andreas
that any impact on that system will be
minimal I think this isn't a this would
be a good time to remind you that if you
have been experiencing earthquakes for
the last 20 years in Southern California
you have been experiencing an extremely
quiet time in California history the
last time we had an earthquake in
Southern California above magnitude 6
was 1999 the previous decade had had
about eight magnitude sixes so this has
been an extremely quiet abnormal time
this type of earthquake is much more
normal for them on the long run we
expect earthquakes of this size it's not
even six and a half the long-term
average is probably once every five or
ten years somewhere in his leathern
Calif
you know remember this is more what we
should be thinking about but is that
there's not more attention underneath oh
yeah wow I would actually say it's about
the same there's Lucy it was explaining
this type of earthquake is more what we
would expect obviously in the earthquake
that occurs releases some of that
tension but there's a tremendous amount
that's built up since the last major
which was in 1857 on the scene yesterday
so these types of earthquakes are kind
of on the fringes of many of the other
more active fault this typically this
type of activity that's actually very
typical we should expect for the next
few hours and idea since I haven't had a
chance to even count the number of
aftershocks so far I can't be accurate
with this one an average six and a half
the largest aftershock is about five and
a half and there would be about ten four
and a half and a hundred three enhance I
think we have already had probably in
excess of twenty three and a half so
that suggests we're on the high side
weird this is not generic this is
probably expected there's a wide
distribution between different sequences
we see factors of 10,000 variation in
the productivity of sequences the
generic is the one I just gave you one
five and a half and four and a half this
seems to be on the high side at the
upper 50% right so I would expect that
there will continue to be magnitude
threes every few minutes as there have
been since this earthquake happened and
that as those many threes come through
we're going to have several fours in
fact there was a four point one that
happened about I don't know something
like a minute ago
somewhere in here I said I think they're
gonna get up about five few years okay
so all right not at this rate however
whatever number you have in the first
day on average the second day has half
that number the third day has a third
that number so 100th day has 1% that
number which is not very many compared
to today but is a lot more than your
background rate now date 110 has point
nine five percent right it's not very
different when you get out into that
tale there's a long tail where we
continue to have earthquakes the last
earthquake clucks - sighs - this is
really Northridge that was a six point
seven the last magnitude five to the
1994 six point seven was in 1997 so for
three years we continued to have
magnitude fives - Northridge the time to
the biggest in in 1999 we had the
hectare minor thwe it was October 16th
about 237 in the morning and it was a
way east of us it was out in the 29
palms Marine Corps weapons testing
center so it was very isolated the
damage was limited because of it it woke
up people across Los Angeles I said 7.1
and that's the last time we've had an
earthquake above six in Southern
California itself Easter Day 2010 there
was a magnitude 7.2 in Baja California
that wasn't felt across much of the
region but it was actually located well
south of the border spring Oh
can you just explain
I'm here for my friends in the Inland
Empire they seem to have felt a lot more
that we did here can you kind of compare
how the shaking would have felt across
our I'm wondering if we can fly yeah
that's what I'm thinkin I can't even get
this let's see okay because if if we
could here's a here's did you feel it
right here you don't seem to me okay I I
will what are you doing wrong that you
resolve that technical issue could you
describe what the field teams do when
they go to look for the okay so an
earthquake actually is the movement of
one site across the other now like with
Northridge that movement happened in the
earth and the fault stopped before it
got to the surface this size earthquake
we have mapped faults there it's
probably through to the surface so what
they are looking for is a place where
one sides moved with respect to the
other so you need something crossing
that fault I mean you can see the
disruption off usually but sometimes
that disruption is just shaking induced
so to be sure that you're seeing fault
offset you need to be sure you see
something that got moved so the first
thing they'll go look for the roads if
there's a road crossing this fault
you'll come along and then there's the
rest of the road as a guess at magnitude
6.4 the offset levels are probably 1 to
5 feet probably a few feet so that means
you cut along yet but the curb of a road
it then just moves over and there's the
rest of it a few feet over if we can
could ever get this in control like we
can bring up some pictures of such
things from previous earthquakes
we don't know okay it is we have just
hit an hour after the earthquake we know
that the system worked but the app has
parameters that says don't give a
message if it's below this level we
don't know it or not because that was
decided okay because of when I felt it
wasn't strong in LA I knew it had to be
pretty far away
of course it if it was down in Sandy you
know the same distance down south it
might have been in San Diego
however 30 minutes before it I had
gotten a message of the for shock that's
it the 4.2 up in this relatively
isolated area so the best guess is that
it's at the same location and that fit
with what I was feeling and assumed that
that's probably what it was can you
describe or explain the characteristics
of the shock waves and why something say
in the West Valley could be felt very
strongly but been five miles away at
Valley Village nothing all right
there's a lot of reasons people feel or
don't feel what
[Music]
technical technical see oh okay yeah
that's really pain room
all right that's shake excuse me
all right so but there's a lot of
reasons you feel what you feel yeah um
it's uh there we go and that's going to
be okay
just magnitude bigger the earthquake
more energies produced distance not from
the epicenter but from the fault surface
in this case that oh look at this 4.2
going on yeah the waves are going to be
arriving here in 27 seconds we probably
won't feel bad
you might feel no expected intensity
right inspecting the right you see this
expected intensity one means one needs
not felt this is the larger S wave here
coming down so this has been larger we
would be probably feeling some shaking
but there's another four right this is
there I think there might have been a
dozen for so far okay so oh that's
that's let's see if we can look at that
I did you feel it so we see it by um
yeah no that's the shake map here I why
do you feel something distant magnitude
distance from the fault local soil
conditions if you're in a flat area you
probably have ground beneath you that
passes the waves through slowly the soil
when the waves move slowly they still
have the same amount of energy they have
to get bigger to carry that same amount
of energy so in a soft soil we amplify
the shaking compared to a hard rock if
you're in Griffith Park you're probably
you know you've got I saw the rock no
soil amplification where we are right
here thickness of this soil it's about a
factor of two amplification can
to being on the Hard Rock Downtown LA's
about a factor of five now you can also
have even smaller more localized ones
when you have like a river channel think
about it if you have a drainage channel
coming out of the mountains that
probably used to be a Greek and that
Creek would have left down soils and
that would have been even softer but let
me see what we've got here okay yeah you
can sort of see it so almost all of LA
we are coming through that's what's
about intensity three intensity three is
noticed by most people inside often
missed by people walking around